hello darkness my old friend I've come  to talk with you again taylor swift's  annual July 4th Squad bash that we  weren't invited to has given us the  greatest gift of all a new internet meme  Ryan Reynolds sad face the internet is  loving it but why is he so sad we have  some theories we have theories he  realizes he's now an accessory to the  conspiracy that is piddle Swift mania  Tom Hiddleston took his wine and now  he's whining he remembers being married  to Scarlett Johansson and you know not  having to hang out with Taylor Swift  maybe he's like oh my gosh I miss Green  Lantern no evil or maybe he is  regretting those lame tattoos we all  just found out about maybe he looked at  his wife and remembered Dan Humphrey was  Gossip Girl and that was the worst  ending to a show ever oh and maybe he's  thinking hey I'm Canadian why am I here  why do you think Ryan Reynolds is so sad  let us know over on the Twitter machines  you want to hear your theories too  thanks for watching